what do you think about this i've said
candidly that
that my
my feeling is that the best jackass
movie was number two just because
we were
in our heyday we were so reckless
everything was working we got away with
everything
and uh jackass 3d was way more
commercially successful
but i think without the phantom camera
the super slow motion the 3d without all
of that i don't know if it i i see
i think you're on this super radical
like you just like the ready to die [ __ ]
right yeah jackass 2 is ready to die
everyone is ready to die willing to die
it's the gnarliest one right very very
right uh
i love 3d i think 3d like what they all
have including what we just shot is the
the spirit of right this camaraderie and
the love of this group and it's got
plenty of gnarly in it but it's it's
really
about this i know you've said that to me
before that each one just has its own
different thing and then you don't know
that until after right you just like
you're not we're not aiming for anything
as we're making them we're just putting
the best [ __ ] in and like maybe maybe my
feeling about jackass 3d is just that
because i was newly sober
like i was just like uncomfortable in my
skin i hadn't found my voice i was just
like this
sort of afraid emotional nerve right
like uh and and then on this one that's
not the case it was incredible you were
able to do 3d like yeah you know that's
a
remember i came in for a screening of
jackass forever like when it was in its
infancy and i walked out of there
thinking man like not even like the the
crazy stunts like of course that's all
in there but just the way that i just
felt comfortable and just like just
throwing out lines just and you look at
it yeah
i'm so happy with it i think this movie
is so damn good thank you i do too it's
[ __ ] i do too and it was against all
odds like
the fact that we pulled this one off you
know unbelievably good and you know
that's probably why you like
two the most because two was probably
the peak of just the
most rotten behavior possible
that was making us laugh at the time it
took so much more like everything in
jackass one wouldn't make jackass two or
a very few a little bit of it would but
right you know like for our gnarly
standard or our gross out or you know
what makes us laugh to what we do to
each other after the shooting goes down
you know i love the way you put that
ready to die they're ready to die bits
and we we have those in the numerator
yeah for sure like everyone stepped up
like if anything
like because here's i know already i'm
gonna get asked a million times what's
it like shooting at jackass maybe now
that you're so much older and very
clearly
the difference is
that
our bones break way easier and it
requires much less to knock us
completely unconscious
and it takes us longer to wake up when
we are completely unconscious
outside of that there's not that much
difference right
so it's it's good for the viewer
yeah and the spirit is like so [ __ ]
alive like it's so much just the
you could feel it the minute we just you
know we went in for that test shoot it
was just like oh
why are we so nervous about this let's
just [ __ ] go i went and saw it and i
feel like this one
you came with me yeah i came with you to
a screen i feel like this one
people were emotionally breaking
in certain bits well we've they've
always done that too
but i feel like i feel like one two
three like it was like [ __ ] this one
they were like i've had it yeah i did i
had that this one made me laugh harder
than any of them yeah like the
my favorite thing in it is the silence
of the lamb spit right
because it's so psychological and it's
so and we we paired everybody up to be
the right person it was like dave and
aaron who are just always paired
together
but
to me that this they're they're like an
old married couple and when they when
they're in their most terrified like
pure right terror they're having they're
bickering with each other about
like dave's like you need to answer me
when i call you if you what the [ __ ] you
need to answer me because aaron goes
full sign he's catatonically silent for
a bit right and then uh and then aaron
breaks into the the bad room
and he's like dave i found a way out and
dave's of course like
yeah you of course you found a way out
here
that one there's nothing's out there
about that [ __ ] so we'll just keep a
lid on that one right right right oh my
god it's it's it's so great yeah we
tortured the guys
and like
we couldn't go out in public much so we
doubled down on the torture of like just
constantly
you know jackass there's always some
like even i get ptsd after one of these
things right i was curiously comfortable
uh on you know like the whole looking
well figured out like well it's [ __ ] man
if i if they get me i'm in the movie and
if they don't if i bust it then i just
don't get in the movie the only thing is
that you know that if your call time to
arrive on set is in the afternoon that
yeah yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]